hi kids
you guys gonna go see pandas daddy's
gonna go make that bacon I asked you a
question
daddy look still not confident okay you
know what you're both right because
daddy loves your boss no no I gotta get
a chance you fixed it
as always you really do love me come on
here gross
listen to me opening those doors from
this floor can't be done anything can be
done at the proper motivation
okay cookie you're gonna bring shower
what he's hauling behind those doors to
me
I'm gonna throw your do love them
you know fall through the fire the
magnets are gonna kick back on once you
pass the plan but I need you pull this
handle in order to engage the braking
system throughout 500 feet from here
until the fire line I want you to count
to five a pool and trust me
you don't have it's okay to be scared in
order to be brave we got to be a little
scared right I need you to be brave
right now you do that for me
yeah would you hold on your mom
deadlift sue me
brace ourselves
better
[Music]
so we lit this entire building on fire
knowing that you would take the most
valuable thing in this world to you and
run and this plan worked the other has
[Music]
I'm gonna get both on what he came here
for as soon as he has to drive you kill
us both
maybe there's my daughter her life is
what matters to me not mine
I'm taking that drive to the roof you
can either be attached to it or not your
choice Joe alright so what's the plan
[Music]
got any duct tape
[Music]
couple wire goes eloping man cried back
up there
mrs. soya
nice to meet you I got them they're in
the park come on kids - that's right
listen to your mommy it's okay
everything's gonna be okay just
[Applause]
[Music]
you ever miss it I haven't touched a gun
in ten years after what happened that
night
I just put my sword down you know we'll
Sawyer's a special character because
when we meet him he's an amputee and
he's just trying to put his life back
together and he guys struggling he finds
love because of that tragedy and he
overcomes well that bad luck you gonna
be okay I never would have met Sarah
never would have my kids daddy loves to
me they love to love it amen
well Sawyer is coming on a job in Hong
Kong he brings his family with them who
needs to inspect a building and it
approved for insurance mr. Sawyer who
are the very first family we've had in
the pool after you secured the
assessment what do you think of the
building the pearl is the most advanced
building in the world but no one really
knows what would happen if things go
wrong
get back whoa whoa whoa whoa you don't
understand my family's in there when
he's forced to take action on his
family's in jeopardy he saddles up I
have to get inside the building and I
can't go up because the fire is there
I'm gonna climb this crane I'm gonna
jump off the crane keep going up don't
look back as good as you can create a
hero you have to create a villain these
bad guys are pretty smart of course boat
dock works for three powerful crime
syndicates and he's high-end muscle for
them
this building has protected something
that I want you going to get it from me
anything can be done at the proper
motivation oh I think there's something
very visceral about a family being torn
apart and the parents doing everything
that they can to protect their young I
wanted to see him be vulnerable it's
just doing anything you can to protect
his family and survive I gotta get you
out of this building
we're suffering up something different
with skyscraper there's a feeling that
you give because a lot of the action
takes place 3,000 feet in the sky upside
down
I'm in real jeopardy on something I
haven't seen before and was really
excited about it's pretty intense
this is stupid
[Music]
one two three
[Music]
[Music]
my family is trapped 240 floors in the
air
so what's the plan whatever it takes we
got
[Music]
ever miss it I haven't touched a gun in
10 years after what happened that night
I just put my sword down you know
without that bad luck you're gonna be
okay
I never would have met Sara I never
would have my kids Danny let's do me
bellows Oh Olivia you matter mr. Sawyer
you are the very first family we've had
in the residential section of the pole
after you secured the assessment what do
you think of the building the pearl is
the most advanced super tall structure
in the world it's a breathtaking
achievement but no one really knows what
would happen if things go wrong hello
boys
I did burn the 96 floors on fire
Sarah listen to me the fire is not gonna
stop keep going up don't stop don't look
back get back
whoa whoa whoa whoa you don't understand
my family's in there
don't tell that was tough
jumped off a supercrime just a mana was
[ __ ] for this building it's
protecting something that I want you're
going to get it for me
anything can be done at the proper
motivation
[Music]
we got to do this guy
it's okay to be scared
in order to be brave you got to be a
little scared I gotta get you out of
this building and I need you to be brave
right now okay yeah Daedalus
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]